on dit toujours les hommes préfèrent les
blondes est ce que les blondes préfère
les noirs il faut demander aux blancs de
faire savoir quelque chose quand même
non mais je pense que c'est comme tout
phénomène de contraste il ya une
attirance ses conclusions n'hésitons et
1 et les cartons c'est vrai il s'attire
est donc c'était des choses comme ça en
plus que ces cds mitzach lèvres un hit
du prix chez quoi du cliché aujourd'hui
c'est le règlement j'adore les étals et
me sens beaucoup plus près les
norvégiennes et une autre femme dans sa
vie c'est celle à qui tu l'as fait deux
enfants est une stylisation on a fait
deux enfants
ouais d'accord ah oui c'est une styliste
inès belge reine silvia bruxelles elle y
ait quelques kilomètres de bourges cher
m'accompagne depuis une dizaine d'années
oui et c'est une affaire qui dure six
mois
disons que je suis un mec qui croient
aux gens dont les gens
pour la tension est forte de l'amour
c'est une fille que j'ai rencontrés
quand je trouvais lancé par didier
lombard est d'abord des plongeurs oui
quand je déposerai et on s'entend très
bien
je pense que ça dure encore mais quand
tu vas chercher tes parents abidjan côte
d'ivoire
comment est ce que ta famille reçoit le
fait que débarque la bike in blanche à
la pause et aussi des problèmes non être
plus disons que c'est vrai que de mon
côté c'était y avait plus de problèmes
que de son côté c'est là-bas que c'est
le plus dur à jouer là bas c'est très
dur il faut dire que ma mère n'étant pas
les traits wade donc elle est encore
plus entre commerçants des parents
paysans commerçants et il ya certaines
choses qu'elle a du mal à comprendre et
non le fait d'avoir deux enfants je
recueille seul problème bien dense et
c'est que il faut qu'elle soit et c'est
convertisse à l'islam alors on t'a vu
tout l'été dans toute la presse à cause
du film de gérard oury
oui c'est une très bonne idée en plus
j'aimerais bien avoir le compte le star
le compte en banque de stade avec sabine
azéma ça va être formidable
non mais c'est vrai que le projet de
gérard c'était un projet magnifique
parce que c'était vraiment d'abord au
départ le projet était proposé à michel
et 9 chez le sénat michel blanc michel
blanc et après on vous pose et noir et
alors
et pourquoi pas la preuve c'est que j'ai
fait le film on se lèche est très très
bien entendu et je crois que ce serait
être prêt gratuit quand on dit de toi
que tu es le eddie murphy français ça te
fait quoi à ton avis
c'est flatteur oui bonjour moi ah ben
non
pourquoi parce que j'aimerais bien que
qui est les journalistes qui puisse dire
à eddie murphy qui quitte à mettre bas
devront coller en fait oui j'ai mis deux
parce que ça me plaisait je remonte sa
de rajouter des séquences un vince et
comme princess erika
oui moi c'est ce que je lui dis ça c'est
un plan dit ali des grands noms de la
frime c'est un plan plus tôt pour voir
un peu où en était cette société
occidentale et danser dans ses rapports
avec les colonies - sans peser viendrait
alors tu aimes pas quand on dit blake
toi parce que tu dis que c'est une façon
je crois que blague c'est un terme usité
c'est importé des états unis je crois
c'est une façon de masquer les choses
c'est pas juste apporter un peu par
hasard vous apportez un extrait d'une
définition du mot [ __ ] qui était dans
un dictionnaire
le petit larousse et l'édition 1886 et
la définition qu il donne ses hommes
femmes à point noir c'est le nom donné
spécialement aux habitants de certaines
contrées de l'afrique de la guinée la
sénégambie etc qui forment une race
d'hommes noirs inférieur en intelligence
à la race france dit race caucasienne
la coloration de la peau paraît être bu
chez les [ __ ] l influence du climat
c'est une modification acquise qui
deviennent transmissibles héréditaire
mais il est généralement reconnu qu'une
femme il est transplanté dans un climat
dans notre climat arrivera à la couleur
blanche après quelques générations et
sans mélange de races tu vois un peu
environ
c'est insensé ça n'a pas de longtemps il
ya d'acier oui et c'est vrai que je
préfère aujourd'hui le mot [ __ ] ça tout
dépend de comment c'est utilisé dans
quel contexte dans quelle situation
c'est une façon sympathique qui peuvent
faire mais oui je vous fait rire parce
que même des gens comme aimé césaire des
gens comme les noirs et les chantres de
la négritude et je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on est francophone et il ya
des mots qui existent pour appeler les
races je vois pas pourquoi on va le
chercher des mois américain je verrai
conteuse alors que je me retrouverais
aux états unis je dirais blacks
je suis en france je m'enfermais et
cette mode des [ __ ] good par exemple
tu en penses quoi tout ça tient le 14
juillet avec des biens qu'ils soient là
mais je crois que c'est bien un moment
je veux dire comme
comme tout mode ya une fin et il faut
pouvoir aller au delà de la mort comme
par exemple situe toujours entre carlton
en 88 quand était à cannes pour pour
chocolat et que le mec ya du baston à
l'entrée culturel j comment c'est le
mépris ou c
ou si la haine c'est même pas la haine
c'est une sorte de déception de
déception d'une civilisation d'une
société qui m'a appris des choses qui a
plus de choses
maras ma culture dont je suis éditeur
comme ça et de voir que en fait j'ai été
berné
en fait j'ai été berné par des gens qui
ne sont pas eux-mêmes fort à l'intérieur
et aujourd'hui quand on n'est pas fort à
l'intérieur je crois qu'on a appelée à
disparaître
oui on devient agressif et je crois
qu'il faut pas répondre par
l'admissibilité parce que moi je les
fais il ya 15 ans quand j'étais à paris
mais cela n'a pas résolu le problème les
noirs dit ni même le problème
je crois qu'il faut passer outre sa et
c'est bizarre parce que tu ne parles de
la mode
c'est vrai que quand je marche dans
paris on se mange des plumes et qui me
dont personne n'en parle ne parle et les
publient match contre pennetta
il y en a eu en particulier qu'il
fallait noir qui allaitent avec un bleu
et blanc dont on ne voit pas le visage
de la femme je trouve que c'est
carrément abjecte comme comme publicité
à venir c'est une décence indécence même
pas digne de ces sociétés là tu vas
retourner un jour là bas c'est un c'est
une utopie
ouais dire c'est l'idée du retour et
quelque chose je crois qui a longtemps
fait défaut en tout cas fait beaucoup de
mal
la communauté noire africaine qui s'est
expatrié qui est venu en europe puisque
tout le temps les gens même quand ils
voulaient pas se l'avouer situé il se
disait qu'ils vont rentrer qui vont
rentrer ce qui fait qu'il ne pouvait pas
vivre non convenablement là où il était
je crois que c'est un danger de vouloir
à tout prix rentrer il faudrait bien là
où on aime ce tour moi je suis une
négropolitain seulement il ya des [ __ ]
africain il ya des [ __ ] américain
moi je suis les gros pots lutins